thing so men really watch what you do
versus what you say and you know you
could you could say I'm not attracted to
money and fame but like if you pick a
guy with money and fame it kind of I'm
I'm making a point where I mean yes but
that's that is the what you get if
you're would he be able to in a Toyota
if he pulled up in a cam like I my my
other like my ex-boyfriend he would play
video games all the time and it was
unattractive because I was wanting to
work with my boyfriend and like that's
interesting what's your screen time the
screen time a lot probably why because
women always talk about men playing
video games but women are addicted to
social media just like men addicted